every time they get in a car by
themselves i worry about what assumption
is being made by somebody who doesn't
know
everything about them michelle obama is
getting candid about the fear she has
for her two daughters
every time they leave the house in an
interview with cbs
this morning co-host gail king the mom
of two says the innocent act of getting
a driver's license
is enough to put fear into the hearts of
black parents
the fact that they are good students and
polite girls but
maybe they're playing their music a
little loud maybe somebody sees the back
of their head
and makes an assumption sasha and malia
who were only 7 and 10 years old when
the obamas entered the white house
are both now in college i've spent my
children's entire life
raising them to be independent confident
young women who are ready to build great
lives for themselves
with malia graduating this year i am
excited for her next chapter that's why
i want to be as excited as every parent
i don't want to have to worry about
her entering a world where she has to
worry about how people would treat her
because of the color of her skin the
former first lady went on to acknowledge
the various
issues we're still facing as a country
including police misconduct
and the work that still needs to be done
to end systemic racism
for me it goes back to we we have to get
to know
each other and so much of what is going
on is that if you've been raised to
assume that all black people are ex
in the case of of interactions with
black men
and police officers sadly it can also
often lead
to death she also opened up about how
the coronavirus pandemic has affected
her mental health
michelle previously admitted to feeling
a low grade of depression
during the past year sometimes we just
need to speak the truth
you know when there is such uncertainty
and unrest
and and and lack of leadership and calm
it is upsetting um it it shakes you
but the point is is that you know there
are dips ebbs and flows to life there
are times when you feel great
and times when you feel really low um
but it's important for us to
to own that that happens to us